Eine sogenannte Computertomographie, kurz CT, ist eine Untersuchung, bei der wir teile
ihres Körpers dreidimensional sehen können.
Das ist eine Röntgen-Untersuchung oder bei dieser Untersuchung verwenden wir Röntgenstrahlen.
Mit dem CT kann man viele Erkrankungen im Körper erkennen.
Die Bilder sind sehr detailliert, also sehr genau.
Sie müssen dabei für etwa zehn Minuten ruhig liegen.
Antwort auf den Einwand von Patienten, sie haben Platzangst oder sie sagen,
ich möchte nicht in die Röhre.
Sie haben vielleicht den Begriff Röhre gehört.
Das ist eine andere Untersuchung, das sogenannte MRT.
Beim CT ist das Gerät kürzer und eigentlich keine richtige Röhre.
Ihr Kopf schaut also auf der anderen Seite des Gerätes wieder heraus
und die Öffnung ist auch nicht so eng wie beim MRT.
Deshalb vertragen auch Patienten mit Platzangst die CT-Untersuchung sehr gut.
Wenn sie sich aber unwohl fühlen sollten, können sie uns das jederzeit sagen.